If you notice, it goes, add, please drop in in comments because I want a person
thank you for dropping this generational advice.
If you want to get a Porsche 911 in 28 days, here's what you need to do.
Go to Airbnb, find a rich guy's list saying, make sure it's in a nice area, screenshot
the page and go to openart.ai-sashdirector, type in this exact prompt with the screenshot.
It will vibe direct to a walk through video and it can make up to five minute long videos.
But here's how you're actually going to make money.
Grow to the bottom of the listing and click message host, sell it to them for $500.
Do this twice a day for the next 28 days and you've got yourself a 911.
So I've been doing this for around a week and already made an absurd amount of money.
And if you don't want to miss out on money, either here's the website we used or just comment
a yeah, I'll send you an entire guy.